que vous luttez pour ce droit de l'homme
est ce que vous avez noté une
amélioration de président contrairement
à ce qu'on croit oui il est certaine que
les violations des droits de l'homme
sont très nombreuses
même dans les pays les plus civilisés il
faut dire que maintenant avec la
télévision avec la presse il ya tout
même pour les victimes
un moyen de se faire entendre à 82 ans
monsieur le président avec une carrière
aussi remplir pour vous pour ce qui
concerne la lutte conte pour les droits
de l'homme est-ce que vous n'assurez pas
un peu à vous reposer a laissé le
flambeau à d'autres pouvant suivre cette
croisade au pour donner le flambeau à
deux précieux suprême donné de suite
parce que les efforts d'un seul homme
sont très insuffisants pour les buts que
je poursuis mais pour me reposer c'est
tout autre chose
à l'heure actuelle j'ai deux grands buts
le premier c'est d'obtenir comme mon
pays ratifient les conventions des
droits de l'homme pour lesquels on
m'envoyait en avant du pape faire tuer
puisque youtube bien vivant mais enfin
propre à créer des bonne doctrine et la
récompense de ma vie serait que mon pays
ratifient ce que je ferme son nom et
puis l institut des droits de l'homme
que j'ai fondé à strasbourg avec le
montant
le principal du montant du prix nobel et
cette tâche là qui est nouvelle
puisqu'elle remonte maintenant je ne
pense pas la terminer de sitôt
mais enfin si j'ai quelques loisirs par
l'abandon de fonction officielle ou de
voyages et bien gelée consacré à écrire
un peu ce que j'ai vu est notamment dans
les étapes de la guerre tels que je les
ai vus je parle de la deuxième guerre
mondiale qu'en fait tu es à londres avec
le français vide
[Musique]